Wow this is pretty heavy thank you
sorry I'm just kinda shaking up here
thank you so much to the Academy thank
you to the Academy staff thank you for
stuffing us with great food and booths
and tons of activities this whole week
and you know really thank you too and
congratulations to all the Academy
winners tonight really very deeply
humbled by this cloud kuhmo I've never
been made without my amazing crew thank
you for all your incredible talent and
efforts and especially to my family and
my friends who supported me and in this
whole process and especially out to my
mom who came all the way from Singapore
she's somewhere here tonight mommy see
any that's is um she's the strongest
woman I know and she saw me what is
strength and to never give up on your
dreams and ideals and helped me a lot
financially when I have no money to pay
for rent and have to put it all in this
film and especially to my husband
Luka Magan ro was here somewhere tonight
ciao baby it's been a wonderful five
months marry you so you know besides
this film I got a husband too and
seriously also a great debt of gratitude
to the Soka Gakkai international for
your firm stance against the non nuclear
weapons in the world because of this you
know I shook hands who have touched that
scorching ground and I hear words come
out from mouth that has tasted ashes in
the air on August 6 and 9 1945 these
people are real and these stories are
very real and the constant
threat of nuclear arsenal is real and we
do not need this in this world today I
think it's no consents that tonight all
the winners majority of our films are
all about the past tragedies that happen
on humanity this someone tonight said to
me that we represent the future of
filmmaking and I think we also represent
the future that's screaming for peace
and love compassion and mutual respect
so together I really hope that we can
all come together and create a culture
of peace and not one of war
last but not least I want to share my
immense gratitude to my life mentor dr.
die said dr. Daisaku Ikeda who
encouraged me to never give up and that
winter will always turn into spring
making this film has not been an easy
path and many times it feels like it's
the harshest winter but tonight tonight
this this is the biggest blossom
distrain thank you